gamescom 2015 is underway on Microsoft
has just kicked things off with this
press conference showing up mini xbox
one games coming later this year and in
2016 one of those there's also coming
other platforms but we played today was
just cause 3 play a little bit of
Justice Corbett this your first time
right yeah my first time playing it I
played quite a bit of just cause 2 but
never really go into the mission stuff
and what I really loved about it was
just being in the world and doing the
crazy maneuverability stuff which is
what I got to play just now so they gave
me access to a bunch of missions one was
destruction but I really focused in on
the Winx in the stuff yeah so the first
thing they did was like a gliding
mission where they just you just hop out
of a helicopter he just lets you kind of
glad your way down and go through rings
kind of like nice type thing but there's
a lot of finesse to the actual movement
which we felt is quite a bit different
from the previous game the previous game
was a lot about just like really large
grapple emotions like you've grappled
onto a building and then that was it you
were just on your way there whereas this
has got loads of like granular grapple
points like the ground and and like
different like small cars and that kind
of stuff to give you a boost around
minded me quite a bit of Batman the way
you'd grapple up to like a ledge of a
building and boost over it so it was
that and I just spent a bunch of time
it's kind of like Greg gliding around
and seeing how maneuverable it was and
it was surprisingly maneuverable between
the kind of grapple the granular grapple
stuff and the parachute you get a lot of
like ability to get around buildings and
underneath the obstacles and I kind of
think it really did feel a lot like that
man and what I loved about it was actual
the way they take like things that
should be bugs and turn them into an
actual feature so there was this moment
where I grapple towards a mountain and
my character Rico just kind of collided
with the mountainside and down stop
which is probably like a collision
glitch where he goes all you did the
belly bounce and I was like come on guy
but then I looked at it and it seems
like they've done they put in unique
animations for all this stuff so when
they did it when I did it a second time
you could see him kind of bouncing surly
a bit and he does things like backflips
I've got a lot of like contextual
animation
for when you're approaching certain
types of vehicles or specific maneuvers
like backflips and barrel rolls and that
kind of stuff I had a lot a lot of fun
just gliding around which is always a
mark of like a really good open world
experience like Batman and crackdown and
even infamous to some extent but it's
like just having the core movement stuff
if that's good enough you know you're in
for something special so I'm quite
confident that this game is going to be
called yeah the wingsuit is a lot of fun
and when I played it for me the most
interesting thing was using the
grappling hooks you take two objects and
smash them together I don't know if you
got to see that today I did it by
accident and I think it was just like
two barrels yeah and I was going towards
them at the same time so it blew up and
then just like to Californy backwards
which is unexpected so if you hold it
the grapple bond it will attach two
things together whereas if you tap it it
just all graph for one thing and then
pull you towards it which is a kind of
thing they used to get used to that
first but it's very very cool i'm
looking forward to kind of like
grappling enemies for things and really
manipulating the environment is it's got
a lot of potential i'm super excited
about it yeah just cause 3 is just like
a massive playground where you can like
blow everything up take to the skies
take to the ground and mix the two
together and I know I enjoyed it quite a
bit it sounds like you did too so for
more games from being calm gamescom 2015
16 gb squad com
you